دفنت الهيئه السعوديه للبيانات والذكاء
الاصطناعي سدايا اليوم مركز التميز للذكاء
الاصطناعي التوليدي بالتعاون مع الشركه
التقنيه العالميه انفيديا خلال الملتقى
اطلاء اطلاق النسخه التجريبيه لتطبيق علان
الذي يعتبر اول تطبيق محادثه باللغه
العربيه في السعوديه هذا التطبيق يقوم
بمحادثه المستخدمين والرد على استفساراتهم
باللغه العربيه الفصحى وكذلك بالعاميه
واحد اثنين ثلاثه
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نصفيان مرحبا بك
كيف تتم التجربه
خلينا نشوف معك على الهواء اهلا بك يا
خالد
طبعا سنتحدث اولا عن هذا المركز وتحديدا
في هذا الوقت وهو مركز التميز الذكاء
الاصطناعي التوليدي وهو التابع الهيئه
السعوديه للبيانات ولا الذكاء الاصطناعي
سدايا طبعا هذا المركز تم تدشينه اليوم
اضافه الى اطلاق برنامج علام وكذلك ايضا
هناك مبادره تهدف الى تدريب اكثر من اربعه
4000 شخص لكن
ساتحدث ايضا عن هذا التطبيق والذي يعتبر
الاول على مستوى المنطقه الذي يطلق في من
خلال خصائصه كالاجابه والرد على استفسارات
من يرغب بالبحث عن معلومه بشكل متزن ودقيق
عموما الدكتور ماجد التويجري وهو المشرف
عام على مركز اعمال الذكاء الاصطناعي هنا
في سدايا مرحبا بك الدكتور يعني اليوم
عندنا اليوم اطلاق لمركز وكذلك
الاطلاق لاول تطبيق وهو تطبيق علام وكذلك
مبادرات اخرى شكرا شكرا اخ هاني المركز
الذكاء الاصطناعي التوليدي جاء في وقت
حساس جدا الان نشهد يعني من بدايه العام
ونهايه العام الماضي انطلاق الذكاء
الاصطناعي التوليدي الان الذكاء الاصطناعي
صار ينتج محتوى صار ينتج صوت صار ينتج
موسيقى فبالتالي مهمه احنا نواكب هذه
التقنيه لذلك وجود مركز وطني متميز للذكاء
الاصطناعي التوليدي مهم والحمد لله تم
توقيع مع شركه عالميه في هذا المجال شركه
فيديا شركه رائده والهدف انه حنا فعلا
نطور الشباب السعودي اليوم انتم شفتم في
المعرض اللي قائمين على المنتجات هذه شباب
سعوديين كفاء باحثين مهندسين في الذكاء
الاصطناعي هذا على سبيل المثال منتج قبل
ما نتكلم هذا هو تطبيق
صحيح ما هو الفرق بين هذا التطبيق علام
وبين ايضا تطبيقات الاخرى لنشاهدها نعم
اولا
اللغه العربيه في التطبيقات الحاليه
التجاريه الموجوده الان ضعيف جدا يعني
الان اللغه العربيه تمثل تقريبا اقل من
خمسه على الف من اللغات الاخرى بالتالي
مصداقيه اللغه العربيه تكون ضعيفه ايضا
تمثيل التاريخ السعودي تمثيل الحضاره
تمثيل الثقافه ضعيف جدا ايضا في امور تخص
الدين وتخص اشياء وهذا بالنسبه لنا هويه
اللغه العربيه هويه واحنا في سدايا عملنا
خطه استراتيجيه لتقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي
التوليدي باللغه العربيه رفعت لمجلس
الاداره وحصلت على دعم كبير من قبل مجلس
الاداره برئاسه سمو ولي العهد رئيس مجلس
اداره سدايا ومنذ ذلك اليوم احنا نعمل على
تطوير هذه المنتجات اللي ت المنتجات
العالميه انا بسوي سيرش يا دكتور معاك
واسوي عمليه بحث بكتب قناه العربيه
وبشوف يعني التفاصيل اللي راح يطلعها عن
قناه العربيه هل هي بالفعل صحيحه وهي فتره
تجريبيه طبعا هذا انا ودي اوضح انه في بعض
الاسئله لو تشوف مثلا من هو وزير الصحه في
المملكه تلقى لنا المعلومه جديده الان
جانا الرد اخباريه السعوديه باللغه
العربيه يعني واضح فيها معلومات وفعلا
يعني القارئ او من يعرف هذه المعلومات
فعلا هي معلومات دقيقه
وواضحه نعم هذه المعلومه عشان تصل بالشكل
هذا هو يبحث من مئات الملايين من قواعد
البيانات الين يحصل على منتج او او رد
بالشكل هذا طبعا حجم تدريب تدريب اللغه
العربيه في هذا المنتج يفوق يعني عدد ضخم
جدا مئات الملايين من الكتب والمقالات
اللغه العربيه
[موسيقى]
باللغه العربيه الموجود تم تدريبها
بالكامل للحصول على هذا المنتج بالشكل
ما راح يعرفني بس اجرب جرب خلينا نشوف
الظاهر لا انا ولا لا
الناس كلها تعرفك يعني الكمبيوتر مو عارفك
يا خالد
لا لا
بكتب بكتب اسمك انا لا لا نصفين
كتبت خالد
خالد مدخلي وخلينا نشوف يتعرف عليك يعني
ما حد عرفك عن الطبيعه
يبحث ويطول ان هذا التدريب غير غير الله
اوكي
طبعا اسماء متشابهه
السؤال وطريقه هذه
وانت تسولف خلينا نشوف النتيجه
متحدثه ان شاء الله انا جالس اكتب من هو
مراسل العربيه لا لا اكتب هذه
المراسل العربيه يعني
هذا المنتج يا ولد يعني المعلومه الحمد
لله صحيحه
وسائل اعلام مختلفه غطى مجموعه واسعه من
الموضوعات والقضايا سمعت يا خالد عرفتك
طبعا المنتج اللي تشوفونه امامكم يقبل
الكلام بالصوت باللهجه العاميه لهجات
سعوديه ايضا لهجه مصريه ويمنيه فممكن
تتكلم بلهجتك ممكن تسولف معاه وتقول لي
اعيد لي الكلام اللي قلته بشكل عربي مرتب
هذه كلها من ضمن الخصائص
يا دكتور الان يعني شاهد برضو ان هناك في
في هذا
نعم الله يحفظك عندك ممكن تعطيه وثيقه
باللغه العربيه ترجمها للانجليزي والفرنسي
ممكن تعطيه وثيقه ويلخصها ممكن يلون
والتلوين يمكن نشوفه
بالشاشه الثانيه
اللي يميز ان التلوين يعرف الالوان
الالوان يعني اعرف ان الشماغ لونه احمر
ويعرف ان البشت المقصب في لون ذهبي وهذه
لن تجدها في الانظمه الثانيه شكرا انك
دكتور ماجد اذا هذا هو تطبيق علامي يعطيك
العافيه دكتور ماجد تعرفه او عرف لنا عن
هذا التطبيق وكذلك الان نتحدث من خلال هنا
مركز التميز الذكاء الاصطناعي التوليدي
سدايا وهذا التطبيق الان هو في مرحله
تجريبيه وايضا سوف يكون في المرحله
المقبله
بين ايادي المستفيدين سواء داخل السعوديه
او خارجها شكرا لك هاني الصفيان
واضح انت معروف في كل مكان يعني لا مش
بعلام بس لحاله
طبعت المزيد
من الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات